on
my mic is on all of your mics are on
hello everyone
uh yeah i started the stream muted just
so that i could make sure everything was
running fine
you should now be able to hear us uh i'm
alana i am joined by
brittany from what's good games miranda
from ign and blessing
from kind of funny where today we are
going to
basically be talking about how each of
us who got to play cyberpunk last week
played it differently and had different
experiences and one thing that's very
cool
this group of people played as different
classes so i played as a street kid
what did everyone else play as nomad
that was a corpo okay yeah i also played
as a nomad so we got two nominations
corbo is honestly the one that's
probably actually the most interesting
to me from the jump
uh blessing so i think we did see this a
little bit in some of the
trailers they released but what i guess
like this will be for all of you but
we'll just start with your blessing is
what literally what happened when you
started the game what was the start of
the game for you so legit the first
thing you do as the corpo is
you you you appear in the bathroom
throwing up into a sink
that's like the legit first thing you're
doing next um
you're basically like this agent for a
big old company called arisaka
um which i guess is like this huge
counter intelligence
uh company um basically as an
agent you answer up to your up to your
higher ups and so
in the bathroom as i was like i don't
know i don't know how i ended up
throwing up legit it just starts with
you just throwing up and so
great after that happens you basically
return
uh to the office and then you then you
go and answer to your boss
who is a guy named jenkins and he he's
basically like
you know i got a thing for you to do he
gets off a call and he calls you over
and he's like hey so
we gotta take out we gotta take this
person out and basically the person he
wants you to take out
is his higher up named abernathy um and
so he hands you this data shard which
has like all her information
her like her family stuff her accounts
basically all the information you need
uh to take her out uh and so from there
you basically take that and you and i
should say within those conversations
you as your character v
you're like uh i don't know if i can do
this like this is like way higher than
me this seems like a very impossible
task but your higher up is basically
pressure you do this thing because if
you don't do it
they're gonna he's gonna mess with you
can i cuss on this podcast
he's going to [ __ ] you up if you don't
follow orders
and so from there uh as v
you then head to uh a bar i think it's
called lizzie's bar
uh where you meet up with jackie who
as v on the corporal path jackie is
a dude who who you've known for a while
uh jackie is the homie jackie is your
friend you guys live like two different
lifestyles because
as the agent you are or as the corporal
you are this this corporate dude who has
all the connections who has a fancy life
who
is you're basically living your best
life as the corporal and jackie is a
dude from the streets jackie is the guy
who has like
the street connections um and so you go
meet up with with jackie to pretty much
talk to him and recruit him to help you
out because
for sv you have no idea how you're going
to accomplish this task
that's super interesting because
basically that makes like jackie the
street kid
yeah and you're like his corporate
friend which is like obviously just
super different
to to i didn't do any of this stuff but
i did go to lizzie's at one point too
um okay later because i have no i have
no idea how any of the other life paths
played out
cool and so like yeah i i go to lizzi's
and i should say that
so from so from uh arisaka which is the
big
uh company building that you're in you
you you basically have like your own
personal vehicle that you that you step
in and i'm not talking about like the
car you drive i'm talking about like
this fancy ass kind of like a like a big
old limo
kind of truck kind of thing it's like a
i think it does talk to you
wow so did you guys finish the demo
yeah not many people not many people did
um so that's the thing worth noting is
like the end of the demo i think
probably has that limo even as a street
kid because
you get changed into basically corporate
clothing
to do this heist you have to pretend to
be a corporate and they give you one of
those vehicles
so uh i really want to ask what is the
inside of the building
look like is culpa blessing like is that
the building you lived in
no um it is this like or maybe actually
i'm not
i'm not sure because that now i'm
thinking of the building so
later on in the game you get your
apartment and all that stuff and i
assume you live in that building but
maybe there's a world where you do live
in the corporate building or in the
arizoca building because
the actual building you live in isn't is
nowhere near as fancy
okay so i think we probably like the
visa apartment we've seen is probably
the same for everyone which is like kind
of slummy
yeah yeah yeah exactly um but yeah the
air socket building is super nice super
sheen
very much like a like a deus ex if you
were playing
the modern days x games very much like a
deus ex kind of building where it is
oh this is the top of the top this is uh
and it's it's kind of militarized at the
same time so it's like military fancy if
that makes sense
uh it's it's it's that type of place and
so
you know you you step out of arisaka you
go you get into your
fancy ass weird car
and basically during my demo this is
actually the point where
um the the vehicle kind of rises and you
start flying toward where lucy's bar is
and you look out the window
or during my demo the person i was
demoing the game with the the
person on the dev team was like hey you
should look out the window just get it
get a peek of the city you know see
what's what it's about and so i look out
the window and yeah you can get
you get to see night city and all of its
glory
from that view which is nice you then
land
uh outside of lizzie's bar you're in a
flying call
yeah oh i didn't do anything in flying
cars yeah someone kept asking me
if if there was any flying cars that's
like not that i saw and i was like oh i
guess so
that is miranda i know yeah i just loved
wildlife
damn that's cool yeah so it must be it
must be like a higher up kind of thing
like only the
the top top of the food chain gets a
rock with the fl with the flying cars
you don't drive it you're
basically you're basically just a
passenger in it um
but yeah you then uh oh you do talk to
it because i remember now having a
conversation of
hey i want you to land over here like
land in front of liz's bar
and you get the feedback of oh there's
nowhere to park and you're just like
just park anywhere and so you park on
this basketball court
and then you get out of the vehicle and
there's the there are these dudes who
are
who are playing basketball they're like
yo what the [ __ ] man like
and then they start trying to attack you
and um
basically you i can't remember the exact
series of events but you basically knock
the first guy out and then you might
like i think you might take the
basketball and knock somebody out with
it i can't remember the exact same
thing but you basically knocked two of
the dudes out and the third dude's like
hey man i don't want to [ __ ] with you
you do what you do um
and so from there what i did was
actually
because the basketball was on the other
side of the court i walked into the
basketball and then
if you click the prompt you can then
take the basketball and shoot and tune
into the hoop
which is a pretty fun thing um from
there
going to lisa's bar i talked to
jackie who's the friend and i'm trying
to like talk him in to help me out with
this thing
and he's like hey man this sounds like a
thing
i don't want to get involved with it
this sounds like a lot in the middle of
that conversation
you're then approached by um a number of
agents
like let's say like three agents they
walk up to you and you're like hey can i
help you guys and they're like um
[ __ ] i can't remember exactly what the
conversation was but i will for like
everyone watching live it is really hard
to remember all of these details when
it's only
four hours and i kept trying to not take
too many notes so that i was playing
like it is really hard
to perfectly recount it so i'm not going
to shame anyone during any of this being
like i don't remember exactly the order
of this because i have that all the time
yeah but basically they approach you and
they're like
hey uh you're coming with us there's
some long lines and you're like
no um and i somehow you figure out that
they are part of abernathy's crew which
abernathy is the person you're after
abernathy is the person that your boss
wants you to take out and so you realize
that they're with abernathy
they then essentially press a button
that shuts you down
they press a button that like causes you
to to kind of have a panic attack
and as that's happening
as it's happening you're seeing uh your
currency like
go all the way down because you have
like you have banks and stuff and you're
saying all that stuff
like your stocks yeah like your stocks i
can't even comprehend this because this
is so different to what i did i'm like
we lived a simple life in our place i
think ours is like actually pretty
pleasant despite the violence like it
was like a pretty cool thing
yeah no this was definitely like a tale
of hey you're you're at the top right
now and in one
one day like everything goes to [ __ ]
because of this one job that your boss
gave you
and so that stuff that starts happening
you start to see your money go down
thankfully
uh you have cash that your boss jenkins
uh gave to you so you have like 5 000
credits or whatever the currency is in
the game
uh that he gave you is it eddie's i
think it's eddie's
yeah exactly named after that yeah
yeah like when you're talking when
you're talking to jenkins earlier he
gave you like a lot of cash
and basically basically your money goes
down except for that water cash that he
gave you so you see every you see
everything go down
you start freaking out you start you
start blacking out and
jackie is like uh jackie like raises his
gun and is like hey
like y'all need to chill and they're
like or what and jackie's like uh
you're in my house like you get the [ __ ]
out or else you know
we'll take you guys out and so they're
basically like hey we did what we came
here to do
this guy is done and so we're gonna
peace out because there's like he he's
obviously done for
um and then from there that's basically
where the game starts where you black
out
and then the next thing i remember is uh
getting to a car with jackie and
you guys pretty pretty much starting
over yeah and the tutorial takes place
and all that stuff which i imagine is
like where we all
take place at the at the same point so
does that mean that you're was your
tutorial also
a hacked militech chip yes that's
interesting because technically
you would have been corpo for the
competing agency for militech
but i think yeah after that intro which
is pretty long we all basically start at
the same point
um so my two nomads do you guys want to
tell the
nomad intro ours is a happier story
of smiling yeah
survival and smuggling um how about i
take
the a little bit of it i'll i'll do like
yeah
yeah so you basically come
to like you're just in a in a garage and
your car is
just broken down and you're trying to
fix it really quickly uh so the nice
thing when you start as a nomad you
start
outside of night city and that was the
thing that made me want to play it
because it's like what does
the world look like in cyberpunk outside
of what we've already seen
uh it's surprised it's just a desert
because you're the other badlands
but could you like drive into the
badlands or did you have to like stay on
the roads
was there anything in the desert there
was well it's called the badlands which
is what the name of it is and there's
it's like i don't know miranda i would
describe it as a dirt road with a bunch
of trailers there's like a little gas
station on the side something you'd find
out in the middle of podunk nowhere
exactly
yeah so you start in this very small
town in the badlands and
so i actually did explore because that
was my entire purpose in playing since
we had ryan did the main preview and for
me because i
think our guide's team i was just like i
am just exploring i don't care how far
i'm making the story i'm gonna do
whatever i can so i like drove to the
edge of the map and had it turned me
around and all that kind of stuff
oh what happened what happened when you
got to the edge of the map it was just
like you can't go
it gave me a flashing message and then
it actually loaded me back in which is
weird
it didn't just force me to turn around
i'm assuming this might be a placeholder
thing
yeah i was gonna ask if that's in the
final build or if that's just what
happened for this demo
yeah uh mike i didn't say whether or not
i could see it just being a placeholder
i could also see it not being a
placeholder because you don't really
have any business driving out to the
edge of the map anyway
i saw a little building and like kind of
a road that cut off so
the first thing i did was check the map
after i had like access to my car and
could drive out of
the station which we'll go back to the
story in a second uh but just to
satisfy the curiosity what up what's out
there uh
it's almost nothing there's not a lot to
find there was one building that you go
to narratively outside of that little
town
and then aside from that i saw this
other building that i wanted to go check
out
but it was past where the map was so i
couldn't actually even go out there
otherwise it's just a dirt road and
desert
to ask a question before you get back to
talking about the nomad
uh stuff i did have a lot of people ask
me and i couldn't answer because i
didn't try
can you walk into most buildings i'm
assuming that you tried if you were
exploring a bunch
yes you can walk into a lot of buildings
not every building but a lot of them
will have like
open structures to where like oh you can
go into this part or it's just like a
door it's not necessarily a loading
i'm loading into another place it's just
can you see into it because there's a
window then usually you can go into
there
i did find that i could go into a lot of
alleyways i didn't expect that had like
other
nooks of just stuff inside uh the store
i keep telling is one of my favorites i
was just driving to the side quest
and then i saw i got a text message for
another side quest where i could go like
hunting somebody down
um i think it's one of the gigs if you
read about that and the tutorial stuff
and uh and so this gig was like a level
five and i was level two so i was like
not happening okay but i'm gonna go in
there and find this person
and i so i i just stopped my car on the
road and like walking into this alleyway
and there was just like this little
restaurant area
and i could just go in there was
literally nothing in there for me to do
i could take
some items like you can take everything
i just took so much [ __ ] like my pockets
are so full of crap
um and uh there's this guy just like
looking out the window just
eating a burger and so i just talked to
him because because you can talk to a
lot of the npcs
so there's like a lot i think pretty
much all of them but they don't
necessarily have engaging things to say
i accidentally almost uh i assaulted an
npc because you couldn't actually talk
to me you could only attack them
i think they're a gang member or
something and so i went up behind you i
was like
just walking up la dee da pressing acts
to talk to them and then i just
assaulted them it's like
okay dude i'm killed by the police
did come after you yeah i didn't see any
cops at all
yeah i only saw cops after i ran over
like three people at a time
and i ran over several people and i also
shot some pedestrians in the face and
didn't have any cops ever come after me
so that's one thing that i'm really
interested in
in that everyone has really different
stories of what triggered police
so i don't know what the rules are i
wonder if it like maybe depends on the
area that you're in
how prevalent they are like the class
system is obviously such a prevalent
thing in this game does it depend on
how expensive the neighborhood is or
does it do they have to actually be in
line of sight when i was asking them
in comparison to gta they were like we
just wanted to make sure it was fun so
we didn't want it to be
like that every time you do something
wrong the cops come after you like i
guess
cd product red made sure that they like
really balance that which i appreciate
because sometimes cops in gta
bit annoying yeah yeah yeah so i
remember i had i know we're like super
off the rails it's fine
it was it was whenever i was going up to
some guy at a noodle stand
and he was eating and so i went behind
him and it just immediately assaulted
him and so it was a really crowded area
and so i think because he was a member
of a gang or something specifically
and i couldn't just default talk to him
then that's why it counted as an assault
rather than just bummer i don't know
that's miranda's power move watch out
for her she'll just walk up behind you
and accidentally assault you
um i do know people out i took judo in
college one of my favorite things i took
with me is like how to
like choke people out did they do it
accurately in cyberpunk 2077
uh i wasn't trying to choke him i was
just holding him so
i think it was like more like like the
throat was here and not like here where
it should be
actually check them out lessons for the
day yeah so you're not supposed to like
hit here you're supposed to hit the
sides and you're cutting off the
blood circulation anyway cyberpunk
yes so back to the nomad introduction
yeah so so you come back to this gas
station and you're just really trying to
quickly get stuff fixed up this guy's
giving you [ __ ]
and you're like you know what i can just
fix this myself so you attempt to fix it
and he's just like you know that car's
gonna break down and it's like i don't
care and so then you get ready to leave
and you have to go to this radio tower
to contact somebody who's helping you
finish a mission
so essentially you because your car
broke down you're late to a meet-up to
go smuggle something into night city and
that's how you're supposed to get into
night city
um because there's actually a whole
border crossing to get into night city
like you can't just drive in and like
have a good day like you have to get
checked out
um so you're getting in your car getting
ready to go to the radio tower
and then the sheriff comes in and he
gives you a lot of [ __ ] because he does
not like people
coming to their town he doesn't take
kindly to strangers
exactly like that yeah and so then uh
he makes a big deal about how and gives
like good context to how nomads are
supposed to be
in a pack essentially like who you
driving with and it's like i'm just by
myself
um essentially like the idea here is
that your character has abandoned their
clan and you are going to go do
something
i have it written down uh there's a
comment about like you should have
joined up with snake nation
like the rest so i guess yeah i heard
that too yes like maybe that's something
within the nomad groups or different
groups that like people defect to or
just go to after
they leave i'm gonna play nomad when i
when i actually play
and i think that one sounds like the
most
uh structure-free i don't know it sounds
like very
like i just feel like it's going to take
you on a very different path to the
other two
i agree especially because it is set
outside of night city
it's like this group that does not exist
within the confines of the walls and it
seems like
no bads are kind of like look down on a
little bit
um so brittany you take it from here
when you
leave the station yeah so you leave the
station and you're going to a telecom
tower to call
your old clan buddy billy mccoy and you
call him
and you're like hey i need you to do me
a solid can you please
help me locate my client like miranda
was saying uh because we have no radio
or whatnot everything's gone to [ __ ] we
need help locating them
so essentially you're asking lily hey
did this person leave a message for me i
need to know where to find them
and willie's like all right i'll help
you this one last time his name is
jackie wells you can find him
essentially like on this trailer in this
trailer down the road or whatnot so
you get in your car and you're driving
around and you get to jackie's trailer
and you're talking to him and he seems
really
nervous and he's definitely like your
first time meeting him he's just
chilling in this i would say miranda was
like kind of like a run down trailer in
the middle of nowhere
yeah they call it a farm but oh that's
right
yeah it was just a trailer that had like
a bunch of crap in it and i can destroy
the fish
tank and i was like yes i call my
apartment a farm
it's it's a beautiful farm you have a
llama thank you lovely yeah
yeah great and he's like well have you
ever smuggled contraband before have you
ever smuggled before and you're like
yeah i'm good i'm good but you can tell
he's like really
nervous almost like miranda i got the
sense that he had never done anything
like this before
yeah like obviously it was a more
intense
smuggling than like maybe had been
involved in
before and i think there was like not a
lot of trust because when you come into
this like you don't know jackie like
he's just
a stranger that you're meeting up with
so i think that's kind of part of the
issues like you guys don't trust each
other from the get-go
and he makes a note of that when you
first meet him like well i'm from night
city he's like we like to talk to each
other before we work together and so you
have an opportunity there to
kind of ask him some questions or
whatnot but uh the long story
you go you put your car up well you go
to your trunk
his trunk where is the cargo he carries
it it's in his farm right that's where
it's at
yeah he has it there in the trailer with
him and then he blows it into the back
of your car he loads in the back your
car and then off you go and there is um
a border crossing there and you get
there and jackie's getting more and more
nervous
and of course your car gets stopped and
you have to go in for further
interrogation
so you leave your car you're walking to
the station and you drop off your weapon
and then you have to go i think it's
like to room number two and then you
talk with an agent there and
i would say at this point i noticed that
half of the people either
were modified or not it was kind of like
a touch and go but the agent we talked
to definitely had some like fancy optics
going on i was like all right
like you can like read my mind or some
[ __ ] i don't trust you
but he uh we ended up bribing the agent
and we're like okay like we think we're
good we think we're
like we're golden and you go back to
your car and now at this point jackie
has taken it upon himself to get in the
driver's seat so
okay fair enough and you get in the car
you start driving
and you can tell v is something's off
she's like some why play as a female v
she's like something's going on like
this isn't right i have a bad feeling
about this
and then sure is [ __ ] arasaka it turns
out your
cargo is corporate property arasaka
property
so then you get into vehicular combat
and it's still it's pretty yeah it's
pretty straightforward it's like you
know you lean out lt
we're playing xbox controller lt to a
mrt to fire what not
there's an aim assist so it wasn't like
super hard to hit what you're trying to
hit
yeah i feel like i haven't spoken about
that before i feel like the vehicle
combat way you know you are leaning
outside of a vehicle shooting people
was standard like yeah it was pretty
alright like
i feel like you lean out very far out of
that vehicle i feel like i was pretty
much outside of the vehicle
hold it on by your you don't need to
lean that far out you know just of
course it would be fine but it doesn't
seem like he's like standing outside of
it but yeah
it's pretty standard solid yeah i don't
feel like i have anything
strong to say about it in either
direction it was it was good it's good
enough for what it needs to be right
yeah um you lose the agents you find a
safe spot
and you open up your cargo in the back
and it is
an iguana and apparently they're very
rare and so they're just like what the
[ __ ] and it's like
it's frozen and so they're like i guess
someone's paying like a lot of money to
get this
and so kind of at that point sorry to
take over no no you're fine yeah i
didn't see a single animal my whole
playthrough
and i think that's wise because in this
game jackie makes the comment i think
that they went extinct 30 years ago
and that someone would pay good money
for it yeah so this is actually
the first of two animals i saw while i
was playing
uh because i hunted the other one down
but you know oh no
so no it's a good thing it's a good
thing so yeah so you get this out and
then you're you
before you actually open the cargo like
you have to talk about jack about like
trust
it's like you know we don't know a lot
of each other maybe we could work
together like obviously this worked out
like
you have my back sort of deal um and
then
of course you open the container you get
the iguana and then the iguana
yeah yeah when you're talking you're
just chatting and then iguana comes up
on you and it's really cute
wow yeah sidebar you said you didn't see
an animal your whole playthrough did you
not see the cat no
that's the second one oh my gosh i
i looked see a cat or the cats i was
like i know
i know there's a freaking feline in this
alleyway i remember
i will find it and i will know if i can
pet this cat
and you can i my cat was bugged out so i
pet the air
i did get through the motion a bunch of
of like very minor bugs
uh while i was playing for the record
and like i've had a lot of people ask me
about like pc specs and stuff we were
all streaming
so we can't tell you pc specs because we
weren't running it um we were all
playing on pc
with xbox controllers i guess you could
have played with the playstation i think
they asked for xbox controllers if i
remember correctly
um but yeah we weren't supposed to play
keyboard and mouse
and yeah there were there were a handful
of bugs across the play through but
nothing that was like
concerning this far out of launch but it
does also explain to me why they pushed
it a bit further
my my biggest ones were audio bugs like
people just not talking when they were
supposed to
that was one of my biggest things coming
out the the the demo was that
yeah i'm glad they're delaying this game
because this game seems super ambitious
and for the sa i probably found around
the same amount of bugs probably like
four or five
among my playthrough which seems like a
lot for four hours but they were like
very small things like the cat thing
which
they said they knew and they were fixing
and um some questing
seemed kind of bug uh
yeah and so like you know i'm i'm glad
they're delaying it for that reason uh
one of my
co-hosts greg asked me uh during our
preview and it kind of made me pause a
little bit
do you guys think this game possibly
gets delayed again uh based on where
it's kind of at now because for me
when he asked me that question i was
like i don't know i could kind of see it
like it seems like there's quite a bit
there to polish
that does but i and and it's also like
worth noting that we played
what they called the pre the the um
prologue
um so we played in theory what they
would have the chunk they've shown the
most that would have been the most
polished chunk
uh that is totally worth noting that
there's so much of this game that and
this is my favorite thing about talking
about it
on that same note is there's so much of
this game that we just don't even know
what it is like
no idea what happens or what it looks
like or where you go just like
absolutely no concept of how big this
game actually gets
so it's kind of hard to say because even
though we played this four hour chunk
i'm like
i don't know so much video game left
i'll also say
with how previews work like that's like
just like a slice that you can work with
and it's like their most stable build or
like a build that they had i played like
i think
i forget what i was playing but they're
like oh yeah this is like a month old or
something but
it's the version that like works best to
show you this particular chunk
so we don't really know what like
version build they are playing on like
how much has changed since or like where
they put all their time and attention
uh they did tell me that they had
changed the uh
car physics to feel a bit more like
forza horizon 4 and i was like oh forza
horizon 4 is probably my favorite racing
game right now i love that series and
they were like oh i wish
we'd known that because we could have
put that build in the demo for you
so even that is obviously still actively
being tweaked
right yeah yeah um so back to
uh padding iguanas
oh yeah and there's this really cute
part with jackie that really sold me
on him as a character he was going i
know he was talking about how he's
always wanted a pet remember i think i
have this right but let me know
and he said he'd always picked out the
name manny and he kind of wanted to keep
the iguana and name him manny and he
kind of went down this little spiel that
was completely unnecessary but super
great for character building i was like
manny you're all right i'm gonna like
you
but at the end of the day you just kind
of shake hands and you decide you're
gonna be partners
jackie says he's gonna help you get a
place to live and then that's when it
skips forward to
like the training segment of the demo
okay so i think yeah we all
end up in the same place um i've spoken
at length on
my channel already about what my intro
was as the street kid but for you guys
i start out in a bar there's this guy
who needs uh
help with money so i go talk to this
other guy who then leads me basically
um to go steal a car and when you get to
the garage which is like there's also
this part where you get in a car with
like a mob boss type guy
um you encounter the sixth street gang
but it's all very much like on the
streets and the slums walking through
that stuff you try to go steal this car
which for the record i believe is named
after
geralt's sword there at least was one
car that in a magazine was was
yeah so i was like oh how many of those
crossovers are we gonna see
yeah exciting stuff um so
you go steal this car it is
uh i guess bugged i don't i don't
remember if it was the chip or
or the car itself but the minute that
you try to open it um jackie shows up
because he's also trying to steal the
car because you're both street kids
and then uh the cops show up very
quickly you kind of get pinned to the
ground
and then the a our osaka
uh member also shows up and
he has been paying the cops off um to
specifically look after
his stuff so it's like an indication of
how corrupt the world is basically
but the cops don't kill you because
you're also from the same area as them
so they don't want to take you out
they're like well he's paying us off so
we'll kind of do what he asks
but at the same time we're going to let
you go because we know where you're from
we're familiar with you
um i also have this backstory for my v
where
they had gone to atlanta for a long time
and then left
huh did you guys have to have that
interesting there's this like backstory
where v went to atlanta
and then came back yeah yeah
it's like a part of the history of
street kid v is like they went to it i
like to think that it's like 20 20
atlanta
yeah it's like why atlanta though but
that's okay i guess you'll probably find
out more
as you play through um but then yeah so
you you kind of
just get knocked out by the cops even
though uh the guy who's paying them off
tells
him tells the cops to kill us and then
you also wake up
and go through the uh tutorial so
if we jump forward um i mean it's longer
than i just made it sound
but uh yeah very much on the streets the
whole time really grounded um there's
one thing i wanted to jump forward to
which we saw in
the e3 demo not last year but the year
before is the
um mouse room gang where you uh you can
go see
meredith stout who i found out is
romancimal and
you go into the maelstrom gang's hideout
and you have to like make that exchange
with the chip
and stuff uh i kind of wanted to know
what how you guys approached that
mission
and what happened um because there are
seven different outcomes
so i'm just kind of assuming that we all
approach things differently so um
blessing uh i guess it would also maybe
be interesting if you're culpo if you
have a different relationship with
meredith stout but i guess she's
militech
i mean i can't even remember like the
details of the um story-wise because i
was kind of focused on just like
[ __ ] around for the most part but
basically i
so the person i was demoing with was
kind of talking to me about
how i could from that point on pretty
much go do side quests or
go mess about and do whatever um
i kind of wanted to just see what was
next in the story and or what was next
to do in the world and so i kind of
mainlined that
and uh if i recall correctly i remember
getting to getting to where the gang's
at and this is the one where you are
trying to
basically make the deal so you can get
like this bipedal kind of thing
yeah yeah and so like i remember getting
getting to that point
having to sit down with them and them
going um
or me being like all right so i gave you
all the money or i gave your guy the
money
uh where is the robot and then being
like um
uh actually this guy i forget what what
happened to him or whatever but like
he's basically not with us anymore yeah
um yeah and they're and they're like no
you gotta pay us again
um because you know we want the money
[ __ ]
um they're super [ __ ] and i remember
having the option of
hey you could pay them if you want or
you can you can convince them to like
cut you
cut you a deal or cut your price or
whatever but because i didn't do
anything before beforehand
i basically did not have that option and
so i kind of had to fight them
um and that's pretty much how that went
down for me i shot up everybody
i think that's basically the same as the
e3 demo that we saw
uh did you guys have the same thing
britney and miranda
yeah so i didn't meet meredith stout i
had called her
and i was like i'm gonna meet you and
then i did it and then she got very mad
at me
no i didn't i spent my extra time doing
the
your nobu arasaka penthouse brain dance
so i went and did that um and i guess
that was optional which i
i wasn't quite sure did you guys do that
one too i did yeah i did that
before blessing you look confused did
you not do the penthouse brain dance
i did do it i was trying to figure out
if which one it was because i'd heard
there were
like i so i know about the two brains
brain dances i did which was the
tutorial one where you're with the
robber and then that penthouse one
and then i've heard about a couple other
ones that people have done and i did not
know they're really
yeah and i didn't know that that
penthouse one was optional i thought it
was like a
a mainline thing yeah i thought it was
optional too i think it said it was but
i think maybe
it's optional do it eventually maybe it
was the order in which you did it that
might have been optional but that's when
i went to lizzy's
uh for the record blessing was my first
time going to lizzie's interesting
my understanding was that yeah the
option was what you choose to do first
because you still have to have the
information to get the chip right
and they have to teach you how to get a
breakdown somehow right so i thought
that was
probably the order uh also i only got to
the brain
dance and i only got to the penthouse
and that's when my time stopped so i
didn't actually do the combat side
because i already knew what happened
there
for for full context the other stuff i
was doing was side quest and exploring
so oh cool yeah i totally want to ask
you about that stuff
but when it came to getting the i know i
didn't talk to meredith and i know if
you do
alana did you talk to her yeah okay i
know she gives you a chip and
you you can use that too wait so oh i
just punched my microphone
so you went to the maelstrom gang
without even getting the chip
from meredith yes interesting
yeah and so when i went to the mouse
room gang at their little hideout some
like grocery store or whatnot that was
kind of funny um my option essentially
was yeah like blessing said you can pay
them off
or you can try to like talk them talk
with them and see like how far
how far that gets you uh for me it
didn't get me very far because my only
two options at the end
were to either aim a gun at him
or because i put so many points into the
attribute
into the body attribute i had the option
to take him out
and so i selected that option and then a
fight ensued and then i
ultimately killed him but yeah so
mine was very different uh to both of
you which i feel like you probably
the the fighting them is probably the
path that it like is the easiest to
follow you towards but
i went to meredith stout she gave me the
chip which is supposed to have 10
000 credits on it because i had so many
points in the tech skill
um i checked the chip basically found
out it had a virus on it which would
have infected the whole of the maelstrom
gang basically
so i got rid of the virus so then
by the time that i got to the maelstrom
gang i actually gave them this chip with
10 000 credits on it and i was also
told them which i think was optional uh
militech gave me this it did have a
virus on it i got rid of the virus for
you
so i never fight the gang
they
because um the minute that that chip is
used i guess it pings militech
so what happened instead was that
militech then broke into the gang
headquarters and started fighting
maelstrom alongside me
uh so i actually mostly didn't even
really engage in combat and just like
watched and let them fight it out the
whole time
and one of the coolest things about that
is uh you guys would have had like a
sort of mini boss fight with the leader
of the gang who's like in this like mech
suit
i didn't have to do that uh militech has
to fight him
so i watched that boss fight that i
would have had to do play out but
because like i said i hacked the ship i
actually paid them
i took the bot i told them that militech
was trying to do them dirty
i just watched that boss fight play out
from their perspective and didn't have
to fight anyone at all and then just
walked out free because militech also
wasn't mad at me
like right so you might want to put the
virus on it you did your job so
yeah did the right thing so did what did
meredith want from you
she i think wants you to use that chip
to infect all of them like she's
intercepting you she kind of beats you
up and intimidates you a bit she's real
mean they actually i think refined her a
bit from one of the e3 demos that we saw
she's
i think sort of everyone actually is a
little less cheesy in their voice acting
and in the dialogue um that they tone
that down in a way that's like everyone
is just more real
um but if i'm trying to like pinpoint
exactly what she wants
did she i think that gameplay is online
i don't know that she even wants the
flathead i think that she
actually just wants you to use that
chip against uh the gang i think here we
go her plan
militech agent meredith stout she wants
the stolen goods back and suspects that
anthony gilchrist her militech rival was
responsible for leaking intel on the bot
to maelstrom
there you go um okay yeah it's very hard
to remember story beats
it's insane
i don't think i did the angry militech
lady yeah i feel like she's pretty much
remember her lady yeah yeah um but yeah
i think that that's like a particularly
interesting thing about the culprit
play-through blessing again is that
she's militech how would she have
interacted with you
right i know yeah i know that there is
something different because ryan
mccaffrey did talk about it because he
also was corporal and did meet
with her um i don't remember exactly
what he said about it but that your
corporate background does play into that
conversation
interesting where do you meet with her
just sort of like in a like
i don't know what the word is they're
all over la just an underpass
right then underpass yeah yeah that's
what i remember from the demo actually
yeah
yeah we've seen that behind closed doors
and i think we've seen gameplay footage
of that too but um it's just sort of in
the middle of nowhere
um but in the gameplay demo that we saw
at e3 jackie
goes with you whereas i didn't take
jackie with me either so i went totally
by myself
i tell them i go by myself and there's a
guy who's like jacked into me who's
checking to see if i'm lying and when
i'm like no i'm here alone they believe
me so yeah she gives me the chip
i i hack it which was a really cool
thing about having the tech skill
because obviously if i just didn't have
that skill
i never would have been able to do that
it totally wouldn't have been an option
i would have uh
probably had the same outcome as you
guys but yeah they did tell me
explicitly there are seven different
outcomes
for that quest which rules that's really
cool
yeah i i think like that's one of the
things that's the most exciting to me
but i don't know that we
would have done any other major quests
that we've all done that we could talk
about in that way about how differently
it would have been
did anyone do any side quests i guess
you would have miranda
i did a netrunner side quest so
you have the option you'll get an
additional chip for like uh netrunning
so essentially hacking other ways and to
other people whenever you scan them
uh and so i did that but it wasn't very
involved which i thought it would be
because it was kind of far out it was
still in that main district we were
exploring which which name i forget
it's like a person's name i saw it in
haywood
watson yeah we're all in watson for the
the main part uh but yeah i know
heywood's the other place that we didn't
get to go to but we
you're confined to that spot so i was
trying to see if i could leave but the
all the other side quests
were either too high above me or had to
be
outside of watson and since like there
was still that lockdown present that you
get when you get to the city
um i couldn't actually leave so
i did the netrunner side quest which
sorry go through my notes really quickly
i feel you girl i took like 12 pages
yeah i saw him tweet that print he was
like i i had a
few but not quite 12 pages because i was
like i need to play through this game
no don't do what i did yeah yeah so it's
from tea bugs so she's like oh hey
i have a netrunner friend i think you
guys probably got the message from her
too like she calls you
and she'll tell you that you can go and
get an extra thing from her for
additional intel and so i went to this
place and it was really funny because
when you walk into this little shop and
so she's i guess one of the vendors you
can work with to get additional
abilities i'm trying to remember all the
classifications of things because
there's so much customization books and
then there's skills and then
yeah this is like a hacking skill
essentially she sells them
and so she teaches she gives you one for
free and she teaches you how to do it i
forget
what it was i think it's like you get to
know who however many people are on a
network or something regarding
people on a network um and so she has
you
test that out and it wasn't very clear
at first
uh you actually have to go like to a
terminal in that building and to use it
there and so you just kind of test it
out and
most of the time that took me to get
there was what made the side quests long
because it wasn't
it was just another pretty much a
glorified tutorial on like how you get
these additional hacks did you see
anything interesting while
driving though so while i went in there
it was kind of cool because
there's this guy in that shop and he's
playing on an arcade machine
and he gets so freaking mad like i just
sit there watching it for a little bit
he starts like beating on the machine
like he's really angry we've been there
um
yeah i was kind of sad because there
wasn't any like default animation for
what the game was but they're like three
different machines and i was like can i
play on these
uh you can't uh but there were also two
people in the back where i guess were
like net running or something
and i scanned both of them and one of
them was just a civilian and one of the
other ones so this was after i got the
optics upgrade
um it was a gang member that i could
take in and it gave me this big alert
it's like hey you can uh this person's
got a bounty and then i was just like
i feel like we're looking at each other
like interesting
i didn't see anyone like that i took
down a cyber psycho
which do you guys not do that no
oh um a cyber psycho is basically it's
it like was very monster hunted to me
which
i guess that kind of sounds the same as
as yos merida with like someone with a
bounty but a cyber psycho is basically
someone who has modified themselves to
the extent that they go insane
and i got like a ping telling me that
there was one on the map that i could go
take down
so i did that that was one of the side
quests that i did uh i killed him and i
guess they will
vary in difficulty he was not
particularly difficult obviously
still in effectively the prologue of the
game and as a reward for doing that um i
got a sniper rifle
that shoots through walls and cover oh
that's very nice
pretty worth it so that was a thing that
i used while getting out of the
gang hideout uh was my sniper rifle did
you get that as part of like a text or
was it part of the
scanner hustles i think it was a test
you know okay so yeah so that was one of
the gigs yeah so
so the idea there is the gigs are tasks
offered by fixers in every area
and so once you enter that area you'll
get a text from that fixer saying like
hey there's all these things you can do
and i think you can find them on the map
as question marks and so then whenever
you get close from those question marks
you'll get a text with the details of
that thing in that area
yes yeah so that's one of the ones i got
on my way to another place and there's
this woman they're like
we have a rad infant station this one
particular rat is causing a bunch of
issues and
it was just like a kiki way of
describing this rpg
yeah who's being pretty awful and
they're like we need to just
exterminate this pest and i'm like and
then she shows a picture of her and
stuff
so the gang member who had the bounty on
them did you receive that information in
the same way or was that
that was completely different that was
just a person who was sitting in the
environment
so that you could like attack and i was
just like oh i don't wanna i wanna deal
with that
yeah my understanding too with the
bounties is that it's just people if you
scan
with your scanner it'll just pop up and
be like hey this person has a bounty and
you can take it or leave it is that
right yeah
yes that's that was my understanding but
they're also so there's those gifts
where people text you to go
take down the target or do something
with them and that will get you some
sort of reward which i didn't do again
because the one that i ran into was too
high of a level
and then they're also the ncpd so night
city police department scanner hustles
so those are different crimes around the
city that you can engage in so one of
them that i found was because i was just
like walking around
and uh i just saw some people just
screaming and running away and i was
like
where are y'all going what's going on
here and so then i walk around the
corner and there's like this shootout
this game like
they're just speaking japanese and like
yelling and they all have guns
and so i was like man i just started i
i'm now in the open world
time to get my gun out
so i i managed to take down like two of
them but i was still getting used to the
combat so
i wanna i know you've also spoken this
at length too that this is not a shooter
and that this is an rpg and so even if
you have killer shooting skills
like you're not gonna necessarily take
down all your opponents as easily as you
would in like a first person shooter
and so even though i was like i took
down about like two or three of them
and there was still more but the
environment i was in was actually really
open
so it was kind of hard to get to behind
cover and like heal myself fast enough
because i was like a level two
and so and these guys are like three and
four or so
and so i i did okay and taking people
out
but then i eventually got killed by
someone who like flanked me around and
then there's another person
but what happens when you die i never
died you just respawned like you could
just say back in
you just go back in yeah just like
exactly the same spot
i was like from where you saved last so
i was like
right back to like i died in the same
places because i had died previously to
the cops in that same area like right
when i got out
so this was like the day time so this
was after
[Music]
after i guess you get to your there were
two points when i came out and i forget
exactly the order
of it but this was yeah a daytime scene
i guess we're going to meet with jackie
to go do something else
um but like before you sit down and get
sushi or while he's eating sushi or
whatever
yeah yeah so i was gonna go meet him
then so on the way to get there i
attacked that guy an accident and died
sorry it's a game that jackie so then
after that he's like get in the car and
i was like nah
and that's when i found those people
screaming and i was like man i gotta get
all this action that's cool
yeah and then i died again and then i
respond like right outside of that area
so like just right outside the
engagement
um and i couldn't tell whether or not
they all respond and
because i just felt like i was wasting
time and i was like oh my god my hours
are ticking i don't have any
time here so i just left and i didn't
continue that engagement but instead i
went up
these stairs and just started exploring
and there's just i was like almost
overwhelmed by how much like [ __ ] there
is to get into
like you just like look at so much stuff
and take so many staircases
and maybe they'll lead to nowhere but
you'll probably pick up some like
condoms and some like handcuffs and some
syringes and some
stuff burritos that's a party right
there
that's awesome no it's sodium
i got a lot of questions when i was
talking about it i didn't get any time
to explore unfortunately but
how did night city feel did it feel
alive did it feel hustle and bustle
because you go into the buildings and
everything you're saying miranda makes
it sound like yeah it does feel alive it
does feel like there's a culture there
and there's a lot to see and do
yeah it definitely did feel that way
like i felt like there's a lot of stuff
i saw somebody asked me if if i didn't
see
enough npcs walking around because
someone i guess had made a complaint
about that but
i felt like they were plentiful if
anything sometimes i was like get out of
my way i'm trying not to run into you
while i'm running
yeah um one thing i did like was
whenever i was driving i felt like there
were fewer cars on the road but whenever
i was walking it felt like there were
more cars
uh i don't know the same way
trying to cross the street and like
looking both ways and like all right
guys be cool
when i'm driving it feels like the roads
are kind of empty yeah but i like
that because i was like i'm the one like
driving on the right side
of like i gotta do the right thing i was
driving correctly too i don't know why
this game made me want to drive
the same thing in gta like i was just
like mostly that i just kind of veer off
because i don't want to deal with people
traffic i hit somebody with my car and i
felt super bad about it in a way where
in gta
i don't give a [ __ ] gta i hit
everybody my sister with my car
in this game i'm just like all right
let's be cool i hit one person i almost
got out to apologize it was that kind of
thing
no i i felt exactly the same way and i
don't actually
know why i felt that way and that in
this instance i really wanted to drive
correctly and maybe it was just easier
to drive correctly but i think it's also
that
things feel a bit more confined like
it's often two lanes with pedestrians on
either side rather than open highways
where like gta can be a lot more
open in terms of the open world and i
think that specific thing is this game
has a lot of very like tight compact
spaces
very dense that's why i think the third
person camera
doesn't work and i get why people want
that and i keep thinking maybe
eventually they'll try to put that in
but i think like with the way they've
designed this world and i'm glad they
designed the wall to be very interesting
first
uh you couldn't really have a third
person camera without the camera
just freaking out on itself at all times
that said it does seem very weird that
it is so customizable and you can spend
so much time in the character creator
and not see your character at all
because i never saw
my video yeah i forgot what my character
looked like 100
i think it was weird i saw my v like
once or twice in a cutscene or something
i didn't get any cutscenes i didn't have
a single cut scene the whole time
well like when you get out of the car
and like you're talking people like i
thought i thought oh yeah
like like this it's cinematics like in
games like more cinematics not like
straight yeah um
i guess i was also a little surprised
that the character crater wasn't as
in-depth as i thought it was going to be
uh more so i will like like to make this
point that
animal crossing has more skin tones than
cyberpunk does
so that's a thing interesting oh uh yeah
and i think
having preset options is fine but it was
fewer than i was expecting
like i had a lot of hairstyles i thought
that was good
pubic hairstyles yeah now people i
really wanted to look at the
pubic hair but i was playing with it
with the person doubling with me and i
was like i don't want to like blessing
yes
i felt that way too weird about that
because i was like
when i was going through the like the
nipple options and like changing the
dicks i like felt weird because again i
know that there's like this person
watching me do you think i talked to
dick real quick
yeah me too yeah like underwear bye
stop the vagina on it and we'll go no
genitals
no nipples no nothing you don't got it
you don't get anything because there it
goes to the show
yeah yeah yeah it is it is strange and i
feel like it's going to be weird for a
lot of people that you can't see your
character really at all but i also
really get why they did that and this
game is so
good in terms of player agency that's
the thing that i keep hopping on about
is
everything i did i chose to do like even
if it's
uh beginning a conversation or a
dialogue sequence it's because you chose
to sit down and do that it doesn't take
control of the camera away from you ever
and i feel like that's like such a
strong part of this game is it
especially compared to like the most
recent thing that i had played through
being the last of us
the difference between like watching
cutscenes or being stuck in animations
to obviously they're completely
different games and naughty dog is doing
that intentionally but it's still just
like so weird to be like i really can
control everything i'm doing and they
never take that away from me only one
time did i have camera control away from
me where it like pulls to something else
which is when meredith stout let her
drone out but otherwise
just absolutely not at all and i really
love that about it again didn't see any
actual cutscenes at all like i'm i'm so
impressed by that and like seeing how
that how they maintain that in a 100
hour game is going to be really really
interesting but
uh to get back on track because i wanted
to talk about different side quests we
did um blessing did you do any any side
content
i did the boxing one i don't know if you
guys can oh i didn't yeah
so it went up yeah toward the towards
the beginning uh
as you're first walking out your your
apartment uh you come across or at least
i came across
uh this a dude boxing was like a robot
ish kind of kind of thing um and so i
went over and i was like hey
you know can i jump in i want to i want
to box because for me i'm down with any
sort of like hand-in-hand combat in
games
and so i did that and then after i i won
the round
um the person who i went up to then uh
directed me towards like an underground
fighting rink kind of thing like a fight
club
essentially and so that was the thing
early on where i was like i want to do
this and i actually didn't circle back
around to until i i finished my main
quest
because i got sidetracked very quickly
when i got back to it though
i basically made my way towards location
which was on a roof
like on a roof in like this kind of if
it feels kind of um like i'm saying
opposites here but on the roof and like
this underground of the city if that
makes sense
um it felt like it was really like i had
a
round thing like a lower section kind of
like go around to kind of find it
um but basically once i got there i had
to fight these twins
who
the the way the way they kind of they
kind of go about it in dialogue is very
interesting because
the way they described it was hey yeah
no we're not twins we're basically
the same person and so like he and i
came here the exact names but he's greg
i'm rob
um we were twins but we figured that we
we do everything together
and we go we get along so well that we
we implanted a chip into both of us and
so now
we're the same consciousness and because
of that they're able to
they're able to subside the rules and
that counts as fighting one person one
person
wow cool i hate that
oh yeah so basically
basically i had to fight both of them at
the same time handing him combat which
was pretty fun and apparently uh this is
what the person who i was playing with
told me
is that that goes that basically goes
down a line of a bunch of fights you
need to do
for the demo only that first fight was
available um yes
second fight in this regard but the
fight with the twins was available and
and
once i won um i could have gone down
that path more if i was playing the full
game
there's a witches request line that's
like that um fable does it
fable one um i think fable2 does does
the same thing i love that stuff but i
also
blessing never did any hand-to-hand
combat aside from stealth takedown so
what is that like
and that was that's why i lived my life
sorry to interrupt really quickly did
you guys do the two additional tutorials
for combat
i did i didn't i left okay i did
was it actually advanced combat yeah
yeah yeah that's what i did too yeah i'm
i tend to face tank in games that's kind
of like what i love to do doesn't always
go well for me especially when the
enemies have guns
but i digress but yeah the the hands
they have was like it was pretty
straightforward i don't know how much
you did get to experience but it's like
you know you
rt to punch hold it strong attack lt to
block and then if you press lt as an
incoming attacks come in and you'll
counter
counter there's there's a katana okay i
know yeah
i was upset that the katana didn't
really come up uh in any of the missions
that
that i did during my playthrough because
i really wanted to use the katana
but the thing i will say about the the
fighting mechanics is that they seem
very simple and it's not much of a fault
because this isn't like a fighting game
but at the same time
um it's it's there it seems to be like a
a core feature of combat so i
kind of wish it felt better in the
moment especially
fighting against two people with the the
way that it
it feels kind of soft like the punches
feel soft when you're blocking them and
also
when you're doing them out and so
fighting against two people
yeah exactly it doesn't have the punch
interesting and so fighting against two
people
kind of felt a bit messy like it did
feel like i'm playing
an rpg where i'm punching people and not
like a
um i don't know like an action game
where i'm punching people
sure and so it was cool um i hope they
i want them to polish it up for the
final one because i i think
the the idea that you can have that as
your your
like one of the main tennis of combat
being fist fighting katana
um guns that's fascinating to me
especially the katana part
um but even when i played with get the
katana i did not have enough street cred
to buy it
it was just during the training during
the training
yeah and during the training it also
felt it felt all right but like
i i wanted to try it out more i wanted
to mess around with that more because
the idea of being able to [ __ ] around
with the katana is seemed really cool
and i'm sure that
there are probably ways you can upgrade
it to make it even cooler like like the
idea of having like a laser katana or i
guess in that case like a light saber
kind of thing
yeah dude now you're speaking my
language yes i expect it i expect it to
be in here somewhere
hell yeah that's again that's the thing
it's like people keep asking me
questions about this game and i'm like i
don't know
like i have no idea what its limits are
i just i have no concept of how far this
goes or how extensive it gets
and i love that about it and i think
it's also very cool that i played four
hours didn't have
hand to hand combat even once but you
had an entire side quest based on it i
didn't even encounter any of that like
that's that's dope but i wonder if it
does get customizable enough that you
could in theory play with a tank build
where brit you can use your fists and
your katana the whole way through
i don't know how to ask you guys the
question of like if we approached combat
differently because i guess
i didn't actually shoot very much i was
focusing on trying to talk my way out of
everything which is the same way that i
played
the witcher 1 especially the witcher 2
and also the witcher 3 so i like very
much
enjoy trying to like use the skill of
speech or whatever to get my way out of
stuff so that's how i probably will end
up playing this game too
uh which means that in combat yeah i
didn't really have to shoot many people
i did some stealth takedowns i did
obviously the gang hideout where
militech and the maelstrom gang were
fighting each other so i didn't really
have to do anything
uh but in that instance i did largely
use my sniper rifle that could shoot
through walls
and i did like mess around with the
shotgun and the pistol a little bit but
i like mostly just like was uninvolved
in combat really at all and very much
played it like an rpg
uh did anyone have like a dramatically
different approach i
so there's the five attributes that you
have right it's body reflex
tech cool and intelligent yes
i think those are the five and then each
one of those five have
three different park trees underneath
and like each perk tree has like 20
different perks you can unlock it's
insane how much you can customize your
character in this
so i just mostly put most of my points
into body and reflex
so i would increase my health um so i
could face tank
and then i put a lot of my points also
into reflex which i think is your main
attribute if you want to focus on
firepower so my main
thing was just like shoot my way through
it punch my way through it
let me be strong enough because some
also that's interesting about the body
attribute is if you get high enough you
can create essentially new passages or
like force new passages open i'm
assuming if there's like a debris in
front of you you can have enough
strength to clear it out
so i think that's more of the way i'm
going to roll i just want to be real
strong
well how did you enjoy that in the demo
like how did that pan out for you
well uh you know i i will admit i'm not
the best at shooting thank god for the
aim assist because oh i need it i'm
gonna punch things shooting things
yep not so well so i mean it was pretty
easy and what i noticed too with the
demo was
every uh quest you did you were
essentially level match i think this
build was just designed that way
so even if you didn't do any of the side
quests because i didn't do a single one
i was always
matched with the quest level so if i was
level two i was doing a level two quest
it was i mean it wasn't i didn't die
once i mean it was easy there was one
point when i was leaving the maelstrom
gang hideout that i just ran out in the
middle of all the gunfire all the
turrets all the sniper rifle and i
managed to survive somehow by punching
people
and running behind and taking cover now
granted i'm assuming in the final build
it won't be that easy especially if
you're not doing that grind from the rpg
doing the side
quest right um but for me it worked out
fine i was able to just
sustain myself that i put all of my
points into health increase
and i increased my fisticuffs and my
reflex so my
rifles are doing more damage my fists
are doing more damage and i had a lot of
health
that's a handy build yeah i was very
much focused on
tech um which i think is the thing that
naturally
ended up helping me get out of
situations with stealth like obviously
by hacking that ship so i think that's
probably a thing that i will do again
because the tech ability also lets you
like hack the building we've seen that
in one of the gameplay videos that got
released as well
um and i think i also focused on body a
fair bit and i do like the cover system
too it's very
wolfenstein um you can lean out behind
cover which i didn't realize initially
but
they did if i remember correctly it
originally had wall running right and
now
does not yes they reported recently that
they don't have wall running because it
just didn't end up working very well
with how the final build turned out or
what their final build's looking like
but there are other mobility options
they set but they didn't detail what
that will be
okay so we had a cover system i know you
could climb over stuff
um yeah crouch but that was really bad
oh yeah you could dash i forgot about
dash yeah yeah yeah that was so easy and
i used that quite a bit because for me
when i went in
i i specced out my character toward the
beginning with the idea that i'm going
to play
stealthy and also doing a lot of hacks
because i like games like deus ex like
belgium solid that's kind of the the
mindset i went
i went in with and then pretty quickly
when i started doing combat i was like
you know what [ __ ] it man i'm shooting
everybody
i very quickly started allocating all my
my points into
i think body and uh reflex
and with that so with the mail stream
mission and quite a few encounters that
i had because like
i the boxing quest was the only side
quest i did but i also did some of the
random activities that just pop up um on
the map
as you're making your way through uh
making your way through town
and so i got into quite a town yeah
that's what i was trying to do i was
like i know there's a song that i can
call you i can't remember
which exact song it is as you're making
your way downtown
uh i so i came i came across quite a few
combat encounters
and i found them really fun honestly i
found them
really enjoyable um the shotgun was kind
of my gun of choice at a certain point
because that thing packs a punch
but that makes with the slide mixed with
the dash i think the dash feels really
good in the game
um i had a blast uh going down that
route
okay so also doable i use the shotgun a
lot too and to me it felt like like an
elaborate taser i don't know if we had
different kinds of shotguns but mine
felt electric uh
yeah in a way that's like i don't know
if that that was intentional or that was
though it just felt like i was using a
really aggressive taser it was cool i
was super into it
yeah i felt like a classic like elmer
flood shotgun
so i ended up going for a high reflex
high cool and cool is like your crit
so i was like i want to be fast it hit
really hard with like critical damage
and so that's kind of the build i went
for but it felt like it didn't really
matter with the combat that i did
i felt like we're not far enough along
to like make
our choices early like really impact the
game that much as far as combat yeah
kind of felt samey but that's not a
fault of cyberpunk it's just that you're
just getting started so you're probably
just kind of
almost more well-rounded even though
like having a point in something else
will do
we'll give you an advantage but at
because you're starting you aren't super
defined yet
um i was really surprised to see all the
upgrades you can get for your body so
it's like it's you're not only
customizing like your stats and like
your points for those
five skills and then you know upgrading
stuff within that
but also like your body is your upgrade
so we got those eyes at first
uh did you guys look through the other
stuff as well
the ripper docks and the cyberware yup
okay got it yeah
look oh there's some good options there
skeleton upgrades there's just so much
stuff that i was like
like looking through both the perks and
the skills and then the cyberware as
well i was like oh my god i'm gonna
drown
and enjoy so much it's like you can
refine like your build
so distinctly too it's kind of crazy
yeah so
cool is entirely about critical hits or
is cool also
dialogue i think cole's also dialogue i
didn't write all of it down
but i know i haven't sorry nerd
so cool is your self-control and
willpower it's stealth how fast npcs
notice you
your crit damage improves effect
resistances and how good of an assassin
you are
so i probably want to do tech and
stealth uh sorry tech and cool actually
yeah realistically yeah yeah i'm super
into that and i think you're right
miranda that it does sound like
um while i was able to like by virtue of
the rpg and the dialogue options
uh aspect of everything i was able to
approach that mission differently but i
do think you're right that it sounds
like we all had a pretty similar
experience with our builds being that
early in the game and that i think it'll
branch out and be really really really
different by the end of the game
yeah i am also bummed i didn't get into
two or didn't force myself to try to get
more combat like i love getting to see
brain downs because that hadn't even
been announced yet and so i was really
excited to get to explore that but
outside i didn't get to do any more
combat after because
i had actually found a sniper uh when i
was exploring
so when i was in that alley uh by
ripperdoc
and that cat uh there's actually an
elevator you can just take up to a
rooftop
just unmarked you can just go into it
and i was like
what really me and
it's just cool to find stuff like that
like that's just not something you have
in a lot of these open world games
i guess like the levels of it is what
really surprised me
um and then up there i found like just a
bunch of trash and some like rare
crafting materials so crafting wasn't in
this game but there's also crafting
yeah yes yes but we didn't get to do any
crafting
yes you do see v's apartment that he or
she has a workbench
um which you can craft on but yeah
crafting was locked up for the purposes
of our build which i'm so curious did
you get any more info about how crafting
works
so i did not i wonder if all the junk
that you have
applies at all i think the junk you have
might just
it could be for crafting maybe you could
scrap it some way to make it into
crafting materials
uh but there is a way to sell all of
your junk
yeah uh there is going to be a sell all
junk button they said yeah it was not
ability that will be there don't worry
which is great because there's a lot of
ways to sell your stuff too uh there's
those uh drop off locations i forgot
what they're called
but yeah like little kiosk ground which
is really close rather than just having
to go to a store
yeah um so we have been been
uh doing this for an hour um and i mean
i could talk about this game for ages
it's very cool because i said this
before we went live but i
have spoken to people about the game
over text but not had a conversation and
it's like it's just so cool for like us
to hear each other talk about it and be
like oh
yeah um but one thing that i wanted to
ask you about was
the dialogue options for your different
uh
life parts like i feel like blessing i'm
particularly interested in corpora
where that's concerned like did you have
any like particularly interesting
dialogue options because i feel like
mine for street kid were mostly just
like
i could give a little bit of context to
something and a lot of them were used
for me to learn more about v's backstory
more so than that what i would do would
change the outcome
i so i felt the kind of the exact same
way about corporal
like i was honestly by the time i
finished it i was a little bit
underwhelmed by the dialogue options
because i was expecting more so of
branching paths and stuff to feel more
meaningful in terms of my relationships
with other characters and
um how situations could play out based
on my dialogue options
for most of what i saw when whenever you
see the corporal thing pop up for a
dialogue option
it was more so uh that dialogue filling
out the world and filling out my
backstory and filling out what's going
on in this situation like
like the thing that seems uh
to persist through the corporal play
through is that you're a dude with
connections like you're a dude
who who knows how to operate um
especially when it comes to
uh interpersonal stuff and and and
knowing the systems and knowing how to
climb
climb your way up um and so like there
was a lot of that but
nothing that felt super substantial in
terms of oh sweet since i'm a corpo
i am now uh on i'm now able to proceed
because of this reason because of this
cool reason that's specific to my
character
though i i feel like there's probably
that stuff in there later down the line
yeah not reflecting in a huge way right
now um but in their
in the first four hours i didn't feel
like that stuff was really as weighty as
i wanted it to be
yeah same for me i think how about my
nomads
i don't even really remember any miranda
i yeah i actually don't remember i think
maybe there was an option for a nomad
thing but i don't really
remember it really impacting much um
i'll say that even though it didn't feel
like it did anything
we when we had an interview with one of
the devs they did say that like your
backstory will have like its own little
side story path that you can follow so
that will impact something at some point
so
it will grow into something but i guess
just for the purposes of the prologue it
is a little bit more
direct uh can i actually ask a question
quickly for you guys
did you see anything or hear anything
about keanu reeves character
no but i think i know where he comes
into play i got a
when i finished the demo you get this
like little
uh montage sizzle reel telling you that
you finished it and
i am of the impression that that heist
we were sent to
um to find the chip that keanu reeves
character is going to be on that ship
based on yeah did you guys get like the
the dialogue in the bar where you're
sitting next to jackie and they're
talking about
like jackie orders a drink um i forget
what the drink is called but like he
essentially like is like
hey can i order a blank and uh
actually i think he might have ordered a
johnny silverhand yeah yeah
it felt like it's referenced though yeah
yeah yeah it's referenced somewhere in
there
yeah there was that and when i was like
exploring my room or my apartment
uh there's actually something on the
radio that references johnny silver it's
like oh here's this music by johnny
silverhand blah blah
and so that's like the only other time i
heard him referenced in the world was
awesome as a musician
interesting but yeah the whole idea that
he gets played into the chip i think has
been pretty implied in the other stuff
as well
uh so it does make sense like this is
the big prologue mission like we're
going to get you guys feet well we're
going to see like
what this is all about how like much
these branching story paths can happen
and how you can approach these things
and then we're going to get into the
actual meat of the story which involves
johnny silverhand
i heard about the relic the first time
when i was it was after the
the second mission where you have to
save save the woman in the bathtub and
you're going down to your apartment and
you're in your elevator
and there are these tvs in the elevator
right and it's the leader of a church
and then the leader of is it arasaka i
believe or not the leader but like a
spokesperson for arasaka
and they're debating the ethics of this
relic right which is you transfer the
dying person's consciousness onto a
relic and then you can essentially
stick their little consciousness inside
of your brain and they can be with you
and that's and i at first i didn't put
two two together i was listening to that
i'm like okay well that makes sense that
sets up
the culture of cyberpunk in this world
and i can see that being a reasonable
thing people would
fight over and then the more i was
thinking about like oh yeah okay
now it makes sense what this probably
really is well i think that's the core
of the game i think that is like the
drive the chip is what the game is
really all about
uh the leader of our soccer is the one
who created it because he wanted to
figure out how to put his own
consciousness on that ship i believe
so i think that's like kind of the
driving story um which
like again i just have no idea where
it's gonna go i'm very excited
this was a really jarring one for me is
like miranda i mean you and i have
previewed tons of games
um not that the other two of you haven't
but been to a lot of preview events with
miranda and i i feel like
this game more than any other game i've
ever previewed i found it
so difficult to know that the next day i
wasn't still playing it
whereas usually i'm like preview event
whatever and maybe that's because it's a
preview event from your own home which
makes it a little bit different
but i was just like oh i got so into
that and you ripped me out of it i know
i have to wait and like of course
everyone does
obviously we are massively privileged
getting to play it early but it was like
i feel like i just got so into it so
fast by how
strong those rpg elements are that uh
i'm like damn it
it is quite surprising just how much
there is
like i the fact that i got through so
much stuff and didn't even see like half
of the rest of the story stuff that you
could see is kind of insane
yeah i felt like i barely scratched the
service when i played oh yeah by the
time i finished i was like man there
i don't know if i did anything at all um
and to what you're saying alana like i
think for me
i'm actually kind of glad that i got to
play this first four hours because now i
kind of know where to
start better uh when i actually do play
and then sit down because now i'm like
all right cool i got an idea of what the
corpo is
uh and hearing other people talk about
the nomad and talk about the street kid
um right now actually both street kid
and nomad are kind of speaking to me
more
than corporal um but yeah now i know i
know how combat feels i know
kind of where i want to spec my
character and and the way i want to play
um which has to be very excited because
this is the type of game where
toward the beginning you it feels like
an embarrassment of riches as far as
what the potential is on where you can
go yeah and
yeah i feel like so many people are
gonna jump and be like okay i'm four
hours in
now i know where to go now i know how i
want to play what i want to do i hope
they release a demo publicly
kind of for that purpose so that people
can kind of get a feel for it before
going in because this is going to be a
really big game and it is going to
involve a lot of decision making and a
lot of choice and like i
just by talking to you guys have now
figured out i am going to do tech and
cool and i was always going to go nomad
pretty much no matter what so
that's the three that i'm gonna focus on
but it's still like
do we know if we're able to respect at
any point has anyone heard anything
about that i don't know if that's even
an option
i haven't heard i don't know i don't
know i could reach out and find out if
that's a thing because
yeah i think you're right blessing that
this is like i keep saying it
this is an rpg it's in first person but
it's not a first person shooter it is
through and through an rpg um it is not
gta
obviously when we're talking about the
cops gta is the easiest comparison to
make in terms of literal gameplay being
very similar
but um i feel like it is it is all about
choice and customization and getting
you know very caught up in those systems
and specking yourself out how you want
to and
i can't wait i'm very excited uh before
we wrap up anyone have any
any closing things that they wanted to
impart uh
if anybody wants to read more about
exploration stuff because there's
a lot i have more concise thoughts on
ign
i wrote just specifically an exploration
preview if you guys want to check that
out
send me the link and i'll put it in the
description of the video when we when we
stop being live
um i think it had some more it's like
small details that i didn't get to
cool yeah i want to check that out too
for sure because you did you approached
it very differently
to um pretty much anyone else so we
appreciate your service
yeah a common question i got to you and
i'd be curious to hear what your
feedback would be
is does this game feel like the witcher
3 at all
and my opinion was if you gave me
cyberpunk
and you gave me the witcher 3 i would
not be able to tell you that this was
the same developer like whatsoever this
just feels so dramatically different
right on so many levels except that you
could summon your call
exactly it's like but a car it just
shows up out of nowhere it's
great but did uh any of you other ladies
pick up on that
or anything i don't so i i i
mean i didn't either but it's a comment
that's something that that i kind of
mentioned
on our first impressions over on
youtube.com those kind of funny games
yeah send me a link everyone just send
me your links for your coverage and i'll
put it in the description
great yeah uh yeah it doesn't feel like
it's the same developer
and in fact in a lot of ways this game
feels like the opposite of witcher 3.
it almost feels like they approached it
going hey we made the witcher 3 and
that's geralt's story and this is
fantasy rpg and we made this thing
let's now go the exact opposite way and
make it rpg where you're not playing a
main charac
you are playing character but you're not
playing this character who has a story
who has this pass and all this stuff
you're playing your own main character
you're playing this first person game
you're in this you're in a cyberpunk
uh city as opposed to like this big
fantasy thing uh and the
yeah the way it feels is different the
way the way you know dialogue flows is
different the way
they they approached everything in this
game feels like such the antithesis to
witcher 3
in a way that has me really excited
because i feel like both of those games
are now
cd projects read or see project red's uh
way of being like hey let's just hit the
both
far ends of the spectrum as far as what
rpgs can be
it's that is the thing that actually has
to be really exciting i respect the hell
out of it
yeah like it's such a it it's the
obstacle it's kind of the opposite of
what we see with with um
rockstar you know we have red dead
redemption 2 and gta 5 in a lot of ways
uh rockstar games for in this isn't like
me trying to bring rockstar into this
conversation and dunk on them but
especially because i love rockstar but
in a lot of ways
those games feel like they're building
off of each other over and over and over
again they iterate on their systems
yeah they're very they're very iterative
um and this feels like
like cd projekt red going no yeah let's
just go a [ __ ] dynamically different
direction
and i think that's just super exciting
yeah very cool
i cannot wait to play it um thank you
guys so much for joining me uh britt
where can everyone find you
you can find me on whatsgoodgames.com or
at blondenerd on twitter
uh blessing how about you you can find
me
at youtube.com kindafunnygames or at
blessingjunior blessingjr on twitter
and miranda and you can find me at
ign.com
our owner guides team please these are
guides thank you
have it girls on twitter guys i'm so
intimidated by this guy but i'm also so
excited
oh my god the guide's going to be a
nightmare oh oh
that wiki page goes like talking to you
guys right now
i'm just gonna like monster i had like a
little freak out i was like
it's all picking we'll be good
uh thank you guys so much for joining me
and thank you to everyone who tuned in
live um hopefully we answered most of
your questions we'll see you guys next
[Music]
time
you